[Music]
so listen mid-1900s your kid growing up
in New York in the lower class and you
spend your childhood seeing your parents
struggling to make ends meet they worry
about making rent they pinch pennies at
every corner and you think to yourself
that there has to be something better
than this that I never want to be poor
again and then you see these local
wiseguys mafia members hanging around
your neighborhood they wear expensive
suits drive classy cars get all the
girls have all this money and look
successful people respect them and they
come man beer basically they're
everything your parents aren't so you
start to idolize them and come to the
conclusion he's a sucker why would I
want to go to school and join the rat
race just to end up like my parents when
I can join the most powerful crime
organization the world has ever seen an
organization so powerful that at the
height of the golden years of the mob
the five main Mafia families were equal
to the size of the top ten US
corporations at the time they controlled
trucking the port's the garbage business
and a lot of the meat produce and fish
markets much of the building trade is in
their hands the carpenters and
electrical unions they have judges on
their payroll and
in their pockets so you set your mind on
becoming a mafioso the only problem is
being that the most successful criminal
organization in the world their inner
workings how to join the mafia and move
up the ranks are filled and secrecy so
if you want to become a successful
mobster you gotta learn the economics of
the Mafia
[Music]
you know what is the the Mafia the Cosa
Nostra as we call it here in America
Colten Oscar is a cult everything that
they do is about making money or we know
criminal organization in the history of
our country has ever infiltrated
legitimate institutions of society the
way the Mafia was able to do the Mafia
is a business but obviously they're not
like many other businesses see a typical
business makes money by providing value
to the world by solving customers
problems Amazon provides value through a
huge selection fast shipping among other
things Google provides the value of
offering the entire human races
collective knowledge at your fingertips
so these companies get paid money in
return for the perceived value they give
out to the world which makes their
owners feel free rich as it should the
problem is providing honest value is
kind of difficult for the most part you
have to work honestly you have to abide
by these silly laws and regulations this
is where the Mafia has an advantage
instead of making money through
providing value they make money by doing
the exact opposite through taking value
so you can think of the mob as sort of
an anti-business an anti business that
isn't restricted by the plebeian las
legitimate businesses or helps you now
of all the different ways they make
money also known as rackets say
protection money if we're trading labor
unions or just some good old-fashioned
robbery most of them revolve around
taking value from people by force take
the classic protection racket for
example mod members go door to door to
mom and pop shops and instead of solving
a problem they already have they create
a problem for them and offer the
solution you have to pay us a hundred
dollars a week so we can protect you
from those no-good criminals who will
break your windows with analyze your
property robbed you and maybe even hurt
your family if they accept great you're
now bringing in four hundred dollars per
month in pure unadulterated cash flow if
they don't well then maybe their windows
would be conveniently shattered in the
next day by some pesky criminals this is
what's called a broken window fallacy
get a hundred brick-and-mortar stores
under your protection and you have
nearly half a million dollars coming in
every single year just from one of your
rackets without having to provide any
value when the Mafia isn't taking value
from people there other rackets operate
kind of like legitimate businesses
providing
to customers by selling illegal stuff
since illegal goods are very profitable
they drugs prostitution illegal gambling
loan-sharking and alcohol back in the
Prohibition days whatever is trending
during the times with all this
racketeering money coming in the mafia
can't just outright spend this dirty
money because the IRS will wonder where
it's all coming from so they'll often
set up legitimate businesses to launder
that money and wipe off all that excess
blood away to make it look legitimate
they'll also get some legal income
coming in so it's a win-win situation
these could be stores legal casinos in
Las Vegas and Atlanta City and many
other fronts one thing the mob does have
in common with regular businesses is
money at the end of the day it's not
about honor respect loyalty God all that
other stuff you see in the Godfather
films - a mafia family the only God you
worship is the Holy dollar and this is
where you come in
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to be a mafioso and command
all the status that you so desperately
crave you have to know your place in the
organization your one and only duty is
to help make the family money more
specifically to make the head of the
family the boss or the Godfather more
cash that is literally all that matters
and there are two ways you can go about
doing this you can be an earner someone
who focuses on making money and giving
it to the family while of course taking
a cut of the money you earn or you can
be a killer after all being that the
Mafia operates outside of the law
they're gonna need someone to enforce
their rules and contracts to make sure
they get their money so if you're a very
astute emotionless killer this role
would be perfect for you and you can get
paid very handsomely the average person
who joins the mob will typically
specialize in one of these two areas
really good at making money or really
good at murder so pick your poison but
if you happen to be one of those rare
breeds as great at both and vicious at
the negotiating table and behind the gun
well you have the potential for a very
successful career you may even have what
it takes to someday be a godfather once
you have an idea of what career path to
take it's time to start climbing the
ranks
[Music]
just like any other well-oiled
organization the military corporations
etc the mob has a very well-defined
hierarchy and structured that you need
to climb this is why it's called
organized crime at the bottom of the
pyramid are associates and this is where
you'll start out any criminal
organizations biggest bottleneck or
people we need great innovative
criminals to run our empire but how do
we recruit them how do we vet them how
do we know that we can trust them this
is where associates come in think of
yourself as an intern you're nobody that
isn't officially part of the family yet
but you're still working under official
family members and helping out in their
rackets you are doing all the groundwork
we did the grunt work for the mob bosses
or the upper echelon mob guys and those
mobsters had power in those days if they
gave you an assignment you couldn't
refuse and you had to do it now this may
not sound like the glamorous gangster
life you were hoping for but great
things take time so meu this as an
opportunity to prove yourself the goal
of an associate is to eventually be
initiated into the Mafia as a made man
with the next rank being a soldier
becoming a made man is the dream of any
aspiring mafioso it means that you're
officially initiated into the life that
you're a part of something bigger than
yourself you command respect status fear
and are considered untouchable by other
criminals if someone so much as
embarrasses you your Mafia brothers will
take care of it this is what we're
working towards so how good are you at
making money for the family how good are
you at taking orders being loyal to the
family are you willing to kill or be
killed how good are you at navigating
around people that will have you killed
and a moment's notice if you said the
wrong thing or offended the wrong person
one mistake the slightest error you're
through they never hesitate to kill a
lot of power plays involved I requires a
lot of emotional intelligence this is
also where you'll start learning the
ropes of the mob and their company
culture out of all the rules of the mob
the biggest rule that must never be
broken if you don't want to get whacked
is what's called omerta their code of
silence to never review the secrets of
life to outsiders or authorities this is
what made the mob appear untouchable in
the eyes of the public and law
enforcement because they just couldn't
get anyone to talk or be an informant
which meant that
if you were prosecuting the mob if you
weren't investigating the mob you really
didn't have access to anybody in the
inside the breaking of omertà is also
what led to the downfall of the mob
which is a story for another video
another interesting world to know is
that mob members never referred to
themselves as the Mafia or the mob or
any other incriminating name like that
to keep out in the public eye and to
Port Authorities the only ever refer to
themselves as La Cosa Nostra or our
thing in Italian in fact for the longest
time there are doubts as to whether or
not the mob even existed and people
claimed it was a mere conspiracy you've
had a number of successes haven't you
for example you've managed to get the
Justice developer to drop the word mafia
in town it was that your doing it was
the voice of all the Italian people
getting the Justice Department of the
United States to ban the use of the word
mafia that's pretty good political power
that is pretty good political dump this
is how good they wore a staying in the
shadows around that time the producer of
The Godfather came to visit Joe Colombo
he sent for him and Joey actually looked
at the script of the Godfather back then
he took any reference to the word mafia
he pulled it out of the script to become
an associate as a teenager is pretty
simple
the mob loves grooming kids from the
streets when they're young they'll start
giving you very small jobs here and
there and if they like you they'll start
giving you more and more responsibility
to be an associate as an adult it's a
little bit trickier it's harder to trust
you as a grown adult and for the most
part it's better to demonstrate your
value and how you can make the money and
let them approach you take Joe Pistone's
case he was an undercover FBI agent
posing as Donnie Brasco a supposed jewel
thief and to become an associate he had
to hang out at the bars and restaurants
the mob members visited to develop
relationships for a whole six months
before he got to work for the family you
don't walk into a mafia place and say
hey you know I'm Donnie Brasco jewel
thief I like to start doing business
with you know yeah holy you know yeah
once you do become an associate it's
game time start making money for love
show them how ambitious you are but not
too ambitious to where you're
threatening people's egos another thing
to keep in mind is that the law favors
bloodlines you don't have to be fully
Italian to be an associate but for the
most part you'll never be able to become
a main man if you're not fully Italian
or if you're
nected to the law and as you gain their
trust as you prove yourself as an earner
or a killer as you show them that you're
an asset that they need in the family
it's time to become a Maine man but
first we have to get our hands a little
bloody again the biggest vulnerability
for a crime organization are its people
so even if an associate has proven
themselves to the family you need some
leverage on them to make sure they stay
committed for life this is where making
your bones come in before you become a
made man one requirement is that you
have to be sponsored by an existing
Maine men another requirement is that
you carry out a hit that you take the
life of another human being in the name
of the family not only will to show how
serious you are about the life but the
family is gonna have a potential murder
conviction to hang over your head to
prevent you from ever turning on them
and once you do hold that trigger and
watch The Life Drain from their eyes
it's time for your initiation ceremony
now you won't know when this will take
place but at a random time you'll get a
call telling you to get dressed
so you'll suit up get picked up in the
car the car will circle around for a
while to avoid any police tails and then
you'll arrive at a random location
you'll walk into a room full of mobsters
and they'll ask you if you know why
you're here by now of course you know
why but you're supposed to say no
they'll put a gun in a knife on a table
to represent that you don't live by God
but that you live and die by the gun and
the knife the boss or the
second-in-command the underboss will
hand you a picture of a saint and prick
your finger you'll let the blood drip
onto the st. Hill like the Saint on fire
and you'll swear your allegiance to the
family as this card burns may my soul
burn in hell if i betray the oath of a
Martha and boom you've gone from
associate to soldier and now you're in
the same ranks as those local gangsters
you grew up idolizing however all those
benefits of being a made man come at a
cost low the main requirement is that
you put the family above all else that
if your wife was dying before your eyes
and the family called you you better
leave your wife in the blink of an eye
[Music]
as an official member of La Cosa Nostra
you're now free to move up the ranks
basically your duty is to help with the
rackets and find new innovative ways to
make money for the family here's how it
works when you were an associate you
work for soldiers and their captain also
known as a capo which you can think of
as the manager who led that crew all the
different crews and the family take
orders from the next level in the chain
of command the underboss who is kind of
like the vice president that can take
over if the boss is taken down he's also
kind of like the family's chief of
operations that can oversee all the
day-to-day happenings of the family's
most lucrative rackets and then you have
the boss also known as that Don or the
Godfather he's like the CEO of the
family and has the final say on all
decisions and finally you have the
families constantly area this is the
family's advisor and the boss's
right-hand man who's usually a trusted
friend and confidants who I'm gonna
continue referring to as the advisor
being the undef Lee butchering this the
advisor is often seen as the third in
command of the family they're also
usually the meteor's and disputes and
are the middlemen between the family and
other crime families and business
associates the reason why it's set up
like this is that not only does it help
with being organized but it also acts as
insulation the few at the top are
insulated from the petty day-to-day
crimes of lows at the bottom it's harder
to prosecute them Colombo as as well as
the other bosses they knew they were
well insulated they had all these
soldiers and all their underlings to do
their criminal bidding and they were
completely untouchable all the crews run
the rackets of the family and as the
money is made it flows up the chain of
command whoever made the money let's say
it's an associate takes their cut the
associate passes the money up to the
soldiers and the capital of the crew
they get their cut and then it's passed
out to be split between the underboss
boss and the advisor so you know how the
business of the mom works how they make
money from rackets and legitimate
businesses you know your role in the
Mafia the company's culture the code of
omerta what they're looking for how it's
structured for insulation and how to
move up the ranks so now it's time to
get out there start working towards
becoming a Manman and being everything
that your parents warrants and who knows
maybe one day you'll even be agog
father open up your joshie bola
welcome to the watch to the end Club if
you guys want more mafia videos like
this all you have to do is let me know
in the comments because if you kind of
tell I'm pretty into this whole
organized crime business if that is the
case and you want more videos like this
you might as well subscribe because I
make video essays like this every single
week for free on the most provocative
stuff in the world business and you can
always dislike an unsub whenever you
want this is awesome the perfect video
to plug that if you want to support this
channels goal financially of making the
world a more curious place one on the
best ways to do that is with our Mafia
themed patreon the Tran crime family you
can start as an associate a soldier or
go all the way in and start out as a
capital all the roles of which you just
learned about which you can join with
the link below another convenient plug
is to join our community this court
server where you can hang out where
other like-minded individuals that are
also into business entrepreneurship
rackets etc with the link below the more
you interact on a server the higher your
social credit score will go thanks to
the Chinese government for the
inspiration also special shout-out to
the moderators that helped manage the
server they're really helpful and have
suggested allow the ideas that make it a
really fun place to hang out which you
can join with the link below but that's
gonna be it for this video you guys
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome
I've been Jake and I'll see you guys in
the next one
give my love you mummy no cake no boards
you come
[Music]